this season's Dancing with the Stars
pros have been revealed and a fan
favorite is back you kind of see it with
a new light and you know I miss being
creative and miss my friends and you
know the timing is right on Thursday
morning good morning america revealed
this season's lineup of dancing pros
with the help of a longtime ballroom
veteran you heard that right
the two-time mirror ball trophy winner
is set to appear this season after
taking a two season break from the show
during his time off mark tied the knot
with BC Jean and starred in Broadway's
Jersey Boys mr. fans I miss that's my
favorite part so I'm looking for they're
being creative and doing what I do best
and that function et caught up with the
31 year olds and his wife earlier this
month and he played coy when asked about
the possibility of returning to the show
what would it take though to get you
back on would it really well
she what what I would have to win I mean
I'm going on there
I mean Never Say Never but it's a little
early to tell in addition to mark the
season 25 pros will include Emma Val
Maxim Lindsay Keough PETA Gleb Artem
Sharna Whitney and for the first time
ever
Alan Byrne stood the newest season kicks
off on September 18th with GMA set to
announce the celebrity cast in a couple
weeks